[Music]
x-men the animated series is widely
beloved by fans of marvel and animation
alike remember wolverine's darkest hour
or the coming of apocalypse keep
watching for the best moments from the
show's run
it doesn't take long for x-men the
animated series to start delivering some
of its most iconic moments the two-part
pilot knight of the sentinels is
absolutely full of them which is one of
the reasons why it makes such a great
introduction to the show's characters if
you happen to get night of the sentinels
on a vhs tape from pizza hut back in the
day then you probably watched it pretty
much constantly throughout the summer of
93. if not well that's what disney plus
is for a few minutes into the episode
the series introduces jubilee a young
mutant who would serve as the audience's
viewpoint character for most of the
series after learning that the
government has dispatched giant robots
to round up mutants she does what most
people do when they get bad news she
goes and plays some video games in her
case it's the arcade at the mall and
it's here that she runs into a problem
jubilee's mutant power mostly involves
shooting pyrotechnic sparks out of her
hand but one of its less convenient side
effects is that she tends to
accidentally make electronics explode
when she gets emotional when this
happens at the arcade the manager gets
understandably angry and this is the
exchange that follows you know how much
that game costs
yeah a quarter talk about a slam dunk
the first proper mission that the x-men
go on in the animated series doesn't
exactly go well while the team does
manage to destroy the government's
database of mutant identities and rescue
jubilee from henry geyrick their victory
comes with a cost during their mission
the shape-shifting x-man known as morph
is apparently killed in action by the
sentinels this of course mostly came as
a shock to the viewers who didn't
realize he'd been created for the show
and was therefore fated to be killed off
in its early stages wolverine takes
morph's death especially hard and he
levels the blame squarely on cyclops for
leaving his fellow mutant behind the dot
which earns old scott summers a punch in
the gut from logan when their fight is
broken up by jean grey wolverine decides
to take out his anger on cyclops in
another way before heading out to drown
his sorrows in a local biker bar
wolverine warms up by slashing his claws
into the roof of scott's boxy early 90s
sports car in a pretty impressive
display of thoroughness he cuts through
the entire frame destroying pretty much
the entire car in the process and when
gene tries to intervene wolverine offers
up a line that hits the signature sweet
spot of equal parts goofy and badass
tell cyclops i made him a convertible
the x-men are arguably the greatest
ensemble in the history of superhero
comics with a roster of characters that
are compelling and well-crafted in their
own right they work best as a team
however playing off each other and
cultivating the connections that form
the addictive drama at the heart of the
group that said it's pretty obvious that
wolverine has been the breakout star for
about 40 years now since shortly after
he joined the team all the way back in
1975 and really he should be wolverine
is a superhero a secret agent a samurai
and a berserker all at once he's got a
fascinating tortured past and his
adamantium claws are straight up iconic
even by x-men standards that's a lot but
it also means there's something for
everyone alike however it also means
that every now and then you have to take
him down a peg case in point the
animated series fifth episode captive
hearts in addition to being the episode
in which this happens it's also the one
where the team faces off against the
morlocks an underground gang of mutants
who have been rejected by society for
their grotesque appearances underground
being the operative word since they
literally live in sewers and subway
tunnels and while beating up the
homeless might not seem like a crime
that would require the attention of the
x-men it soon turns out the morlocks are
more formidable than anyone could have
imagined so when wolverine tries to
fight anna lee she casts a telepathic
illusion that makes wolverine think that
he is as she says
covered with scorpions
covered with skull no
covered with scorpions how's that for a
humbling experience
the debate over whether comic books have
any real educational or literary value
has been raging for about as long as
they've existed even today when comic
books are criticized as childish or
simple the people who defend them will
usually cite the same couple of examples
from 35 years ago such as watchmen or
mouse nothing against those books of
course but it's always worth mentioning
that the x-men have been serving as a
long-running and hugely important
metaphor for the struggles against
bigotry and inequality for decades this
metaphor is explored many times in the
comics but one of the best instances
occurs in the animated series in the
show's third episode inter magneto beast
is put on trial for breaking into the
mutant control agency's headquarters and
destroying the records that they were
using to round up mutants as part of his
defense beast paraphrases shakespeare's
the merchant of venice trying to
convince both the judge and the
assembled crowd that mutants and humans
are the same if you prick us
do we not bleed is it corny sure is it
also the perfect way for noted turbo
nerd hank mccoy to make his point while
also sparking an interest in shakespeare
for the show's younger audience
absolutely despite the inherent
goofiness of this moment it's part of
one of the best acted scenes in the
whole series one that is only made more
affecting by the fact that despite his
moral high ground beast is denied bail
anyway teaching kids about the enduring
themes of shakespeare is one thing but
teaching them that the system can be
stacked against their heroes is
something else entirely
in the first episode of the animated
series the mutant gambit is introduced
doing three things hitting on a girl
working at a store that sells a
suspicious amount of playing cards
shoplifting a deck when the girl gets
distracted by killer robots and
suggesting she get insurance to pay for
the subsequent damage and his sleazy
uncle vibes only get more intense as the
show goes on gambit's absolute best or
worst moment comes in the sixth episode
cold vengeance in which the x-men
investigate the island of jenosha unlike
other countries this tropical paradise
has been extremely welcoming to the
mutant population and the team decides
that they need to check it out to see if
their kindness is legit spoil a warning
for a tv show from almost 30 years ago
it's not the infiltration team is made
up of storm jubilee and gambit who visit
the island under the pretense that
they're average non-mutant taurus aside
from the extremely dubious tactic of
sending a 15 year old who shoots
fireworks out of her hands on an
undercover mission the funniest moment
of the episodes comes when the trio is
checking into the hotel here gambit
notices a sign indicating a mutant
discount being a professional thief
gambit turns to storm and asks
what do you think we save maybe ten
percent
just put it back gambit this is a guy
who was willing to put the entire mutant
population of the world at risk for the
sake of at most fifty dollars you've
gotta admire a hustle like that
the greatest tragedy of the x-men the
animated series is that in the show's
entire 76 episode run there's only one
holiday special season fours have
yourself a morlock little christmas the
good news though is that it's absolutely
fantastic first there's the opening
scene in which cyclops sings deck the
halls so poorly that you genuinely can't
help but wonder if he's ever heard a
song in his life much less a christmas
carol and there's the bizarre church
bell and trumpet remix of the theme song
that plays in the background in a few
key scenes the best moment by far
however involves gambit and jean grey
cooking up christmas dinner for one
thing these two characters seem to
despise each other with a fever that
makes wolverine and cyclops look like
batman and robert at least as far as
their time in the kitchen is concerned
gambit fires the first shot by wretching
in disgust after tasting some of gene's
cooking and by the time he's trying to
give the ham a so-called juicing up gene
is threatening to beat him to death with
a gigantic piece of broccoli unless he
leaves the kitchen in the grandest and
most long-standing marvel tradition the
two characters end up taking a
fight-then-team-up approach to dinner
only to find that the rest of the group
has decided to spend christmas with the
morlocks instead when gene suggests that
they just warm it all up in the
microwave on the 26 gambit replies with
the show's most intense line read by far
gambit does not make tv dinners
sometimes the best parts of a show
aren't the goofy subplots or the
compelling dramatic beats sometimes you
just need to see something flat out
awesome take season ones come the
apocalypse for example there's a lot to
like about this episode in terms of
classic action-packed x-men thrills the
main plot finds apocalypse gathering up
disaffected mutants in order to find his
four horsemen while rogue faces an
internal struggle over the possibility
of losing her powers via a new mutant
cure the best moment though comes at the
end of the episode after he's revealed
that the sinister mastermind behind the
mutant cure and his horsemen are
defeated apocalypse decides to bail so
naturally he takes his secret elevator
down to his secret headquarters under
stonehenge and then flies away in the
transforming spaceship that he hid there
a thousand years ago it doesn't hurt to
take a step back and actually think
about what you've just watched a
spaceship emerging from stonehenge after
a battle between super-evolved humans
and the four horsemen of the apocalypse
this kind of thing is exactly why people
love superhero stories
one of the coolest things about the
animated series is how it hints at the
long history of both the x-men and the
wider marvel universe some episodes
feature flashbacks to the early days of
the original x-men while others make
offhand references to characters such as
deadpool and punisher occasionally the
show throws in a full cameo too this
sort of thing only really heated up once
spider-man the animated series hit their
airwaves in 1994 paving the way for its
own set of crossovers but x-men got the
ball rolling and the show's biggest
crossover was also one of the best
episodes of the series old soldiers is
one of the few high spots in x-men's
final season the superhero show was
originally meant to end after season 4's
multi-part beyond good and evil saga and
the last minute reprieve meant a change
of animation studios and a less than
stellar redesign for the main characters
this episode though made it all worth it
old soldiers is very loosely inspired by
uncanny x-men number 268 the classic
story in which captain america and
wolverine team up to rescue a young
black widow from nazis the animated
version doesn't have black widow but it
does have cap and wolverine taking on
hitler's minions in their secret weapon
a giant killer robot commissioned by the
red skull it can't be overstated how
awesome this was for kids of the 90s the
runaway success of the mcu means marvel
crossovers are commonplace nowadays but
old soldiers was a novelty at the time
it was captain america showing up on an
x-men tv series if you were a kid who
loved marvel comics then cap showing up
in all his nazi stomping glory was a
treat all on its own check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]